the phillies will have chase anderson on
the mound a one and three mark with a 5
40 earned run average anderson a
one-time milwaukee brewer that'll bring
up travis shaw
outfield pretty much straight away
mccutcheon not as deep as the other two
and a high papa
near the second base bag gregorius gets
to a spot the wind is whipping and he
makes the catch
and the side is retired it's a 20-pitch
inning no runs no hits a man left middle
of the first brewers nothing and the
philly's coming up the brewers meanwhile
will have freddie peralta on the mound
peralta is off to a tremendous start
he's got a 3-0 mark and a 2.25 era
there's rhys hoskins
241 average with eight homers
going two to hoskins
and reese lines what it to right center
field to base it the phils will get a
run early mccutcheon will score going to
third miller holding it first hoskins
rbi single one-nothing phillips
and the bases are loaded
d d gregorius is coming up and for
freddie peralta this is when he's got to
get
and tough high fly ball to deep right
field garcia going back it is gone
grand slam dede gregorius
he loves hitting with the bases loaded
and the phillies lead it five nothing
here in the bottom of the first inning
fourth homer of the season for dede
gregorius it's a grand slam and the
phillies
with a five-nothing lead here in the
bottom of the first inning
and now oh double herrera is the hitter
2-2 to odubal herrera
struck him out looking
and the inning finally ends 33 pitches
for freddie peralta
the big grand slam from d.d gregory has
work to do for the brewers offense when
we come back it's 5-0 philadelphia as we
head to the second jackie bradley jr the
batter hitting 188 with three homers
jackie bradley jr hitting 188 three home
runs
shallow right field that's way up there
maton is there miller comes in and
miller
afraid he's going to run into natan took
a knee
and there's one out
two away here in the second inning for
brad miller
one two
fastballs swinging a miss freddie
peralta struck out six in a row we head
to the third inning
it's five nothing phillies and the bases
are loaded for garcia
brewers left nine on base last night
left eight on base
on monday night
they've left two already here tonight
looking for a clutch hit
one one pitch and this is driven into
center field coming in as herrera it's
gonna drop in front of him
herrera is going to throw home one run
is in bogo back slides in there he's
safe
and boggleback is down in a little bit
of pain now he pops up says he's okay as
he
jumps up and runs back into the dugout
a two-run
base hit for uh visa garcia he ends up
at second on the throw and the brewers
have him at second and third it's a 5-2
ball game maybe he blocked him i don't
know his foot's up in the air
he's out
marvin hudson to your left will make the
call he's the crew chief
yeah all right all right
so a break for the fills
on the slide by vogelback
oh double gets the outfield assist it's
a 5-1 game
and it could have been a whole lot worse
yeah that'll bring maylie up
two balls and two strikes on luke maley
here's the pitch
swinging to miss pulled the string and
he got it
now that's strikeout number two for
chase anderson gets a one two three
inning
[Applause]
we have played
three and a half to the bottom of the
fourth five one fills
freddie peralta's spot is scheduled
to lead off
this top of the fifth inning but tyrone
taylor's gonna hit
taylor
pinch hitting a 303 banning average for
tyrone a couple of home runs he's driven
in seven
was in the lineup last night went over
two
2-0 pitch from anderson
swinging a shot to deep left center
field it's gone
home run tyrone taylor is a pinch hitter
it's 5-2 now
that one got out of here in a hurry
anderson gives up
his fourth home run of the season
that one got out at 109 miles an hour
off the bat at tyrone taylor center cut
fastball no doubt about it
and it brings travis shaw
back toward the middle off the glove of
jojo romero he's got it from his knees
he's able to rebound and throw the
runner out at first that is a heck of a
play there's avi garcia two for two
one and two on avi garcia
here he comes swinging a ground ball hey
towards the middle of base hit
kane scores
vogelback's coming around he's going to
score it's a one-run game
five to four on the third hit of the
night
for avi garcia
two outs here in the inning two runners
on the tying run is at second the
go-ahead run at first
pablo reyes about to bat his
eighth man up in the inning and the
pitch
strike three called got him looking
on the outside corner
and reyes goes down on strikes and
brandon kinsler holds the lead
three runs in the inning for milwaukee
they do it with three hits and they
leave two men aboard and we'll go to the
bottom of the fifth inning abilities
five and the brewers four
comes tyrone taylor
back toward the middle flanked down by
kinsler there's one and two
i thought he caught that in the air i
didn't see it bounce took one big bounce
right
in front of the plate
it was smokes
pablo reyes
coming up
out to shallow right field miller comes
in and over toward the line in foul
territory makes the catch as he goes to
the grounds
that's going to bring tyrone taylor to
the plate one ball two strikes two outs
two on
and the pitch swinging a ground ball hit
to short coming in dede he's got it goes
to second and they force out melee and
enlarge
holds the lead
here in the eighth no runs a hit a hit
batter and two left will go to the
bottom of the eighth phillies five and
the brewers four still one more to get
as travis shaw is coming up the last
time they had seven straight one run
games was back in 1980
one and two to shaw
alvarado set to go and the pitch
swing and a miss he got him 99 at the
knees
another one run victory for the bills
five for the final score